this is a big honor for me right now I'm
standing with Massimo Banzi co-founder
of Arduino a Massimo this is amazing the
arduino movement is absolutely
astounding is this anything that you
ever expected no are you crazy not as
none of these I ever expected you at the
beginning was just a tool that we
developed for students and you know it
all thanks to the community that formed
around it to the people who believed in
it and I went around the world's only
people you just check you need to check
out this Arduino it seems like one of
the big things that people have really
latched onto with Arduino is that
Arduino is an open-source microprocessor
that you can use to control just about
any type of robotic electronic project
that you want to create we open source
the design of the hardware as well so
people were used all ready to open
source software but then we decided that
we wanted everybody to be able to make
their own or build upon our work so we
share those of the design of the
hardware and I think this is one of the
elements that made it very popular on
top of the fact that we try to make it
simple as well what are some of the most
amazing and surprising projects that
you've seen so far when I saw the first
3d printer like the MakerBot based on
Arduino I was like whoa okay 3d printers
then somebody start to make a laser
cutter that was open source with the
Arduino and then somebody made a machine
that you used to analyze DNA which is
based on our doing so every day is like
more complex and more I can say a
project that has an impact on on society
and can help people you know maybe in a
developing country get the equipment
they need to do scientific experiments
by spending a lot more money by building
their own tool so it's it's difficult to
see what it will go now where do you see
all of this going what's coming up next
well we're trying to provide the
community with more powerful tools so
we're launching now a new board which is
based on a 32-bit arm microcontroller so
this is will basically enable people to
do more complex project more powerful
stuff I mean if you think about it you
know Chris Anderson is building this
Ella copters that fly by themselves and
he basically pushed the Arduino platform
to the very limit they just squeezing
out all the power so this new marred we
know do it we're working on will enable
his team to make even a more complex and
and fun quadcopter or UAV so you know
that's amazing for me arduino do way
arduino to what's uh what's a release
day for that when is that coming out
well we're starting to essentially hand
out the boards now 250 people will join
the beta program and it will help us in
the next month or two and then we have a
couple of big companies i cannot tell
you about right now that are going to
release products based on data and then
before the before the summer it will be
available to anybody to buy you
something of a personal hero so i wanted
to ask a favor i was wondering if i
actually brought my my own arduino i was
wondering if I could have you autograph
this for me okay this is 0 this is a
vintage one with an Italian map at the
back beautiful you won't be seeing this
on ebay this one I'm keeping I don't
know what to say sometimes there's so
much long in the Arduino community it's
true
you